ah
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález minuto a
minuto van sucediendo muchas cosas en
cuanto a la crisis en ucrania país que
decretó el estado de emergencia y pidió
a los ciudadanos ucranianos residentes
en rusia a abandonar el país por su
propia seguridad asimismo rusia también
comenzó a evacuar parte de su personal
diplomático desplegado en otra en
ucrania evacuó y también cerró la
embajada que tiene en la ciudad de kiev
del otro lado del atlántico
recientemente eeuu y bueno también la
unión europea apostaron por imponer
sanciones a rusia después de que el
presidente vladimir putin reconociera la
soberanía de las repúblicas de daniel y
lugansk en la región del donbass que son
el foco del enfrentamiento desde el año
la idea de washington es que rusia no
pueda captar dinero en occidente y
tampoco pueda negociar deuda a nivel
internacional a través de los mercados
de eeuu y de europa veamos de qué se
trata
esto corresponde a ese primer tramo de
sanciones de estados unidos a rusia
presentadas por el presidente de eeuu
joe biden en eeuu entonces bloqueó los
bancos bbva y psv el primero es
considerado como una especie de fondo de
inversión del estado ruso es señalado
por occidente de servir para realizar
sobornos pero esto nunca han dado
pruebas sobre ello el segundo banco fue
nacionalizado y dejado como una especie
de soporte bancario y financiero para la
industria militar rusa ante los ojos de
occidente es un banco que fue
nacionalizado a propósito para que fuera
blanco de este tipo de sanciones
internacionales y no generará mayores
traumatismos dentro de las finanzas
públicas en la federación de rusia eeuu
también impuso sanciones integrales
contra la deuda soberana de rusia de
este modo washington como les decía
espera que rusia no pueda acceder a
mercados internacionales oa dólares para
financiar su deuda también hay sanciones
a las élites rusas y a sus familiares
también a funcionarios públicos y
personalidades que son cercanas al
kremlin que están a la cabeza de
organismos público entidades financieras
corporaciones y empresas que también a
su vez son cercanas al presidente
vladimir putin previamente eeuu ya había
establecido una prohibición a sus
ciudadanos y empresarios y les prohibía
comerciar o realizar transacciones con
las regiones separatistas de doñetsk
lugansk
a grandes rasgos pues esas son las
medidas que comenzarán a regir de pronto
y mostrarán sus efectos en la economía
rusa pero también la unión europea y el
reino unido también han impuesto algunas
sanciones veamos de qué se trata
desde bruselas anunciaron que los 27
países integrantes de la unión acordaron
sanciones que deben ser determinadas en
las próximas horas pero apuntan a que
estas sanciones
deben congelar entonces los activos de
rusia que hay en la unión europea
también prohibir los visados para 351
diputados de la duma estatal rusa que la
cámara baja del parlamento ruso que
aprobaron el reconocimiento de
autodeterminación de las dos regiones
separatistas de unience y lugansk
también sancionarán entidades y también
organizaciones que contribuyan a socavar
o amenazar la integridad territorial e
independencia de ucrania de otra parte
alemania por su parte anunció que
pospondrá las certificaciones del
gasoducto nord stream 2 que ya está
terminado está listo para funcionar y
solo tiene pendiente la certificación
para garantizar el suministro de gas
desde la ciudad de víborg en el golfo de
finlandia en la costa rusa hasta la
costa del norte de alemania en el mar
báltico
quedan muchas preguntas sobre la mesa
qué tan efectivas eran estas sanciones
cumplirán el objetivo que tiene en mente
washington y bruselas que tan preparada
hasta rusia para hacer frente a este
nuevo tramo de sanciones que vienen y
poniendo los países de occidente desde
el año 2014 ya rusia ha sentido una
presión económica y una caída de la
moneda local el rublo por las acciones
de washington y de bruselas cómo afecta
esto a ucrania que es el país que está
en el centro de la crisis contiene o
agudiza esta crisis estas sanciones
impuestas por occidente es nuestro tema
de debate en france 24 pero antes
escuchemos algunas de las reacciones que
ha habido a lo largo del día de hoy
después de imponer estas sanciones el
presidente de ucrania volodymyr selenski
habló sobre la importancia de estas
sanciones impuestas por occidente para
hacer frente a la crisis que se está
viviendo en su país escuchamos
la respuesta de la comunidad
internacional a esos crímenes debe ser
decisiva inmediata y contundente
diseñan ucrania acoge con satisfacción
los anuncios de ayer y anteayer sobre
las sanciones contra la federación
guasave realizados por la unión europea
eeuu y gran bretaña y canadá esperamos
otras sanciones más fuertes
y el presidente ucraniano con esto
demuestra que occidente sigue de su lado
apoyándolo para hacer frente a esta
presión que recibió cráneo por parte del
kremlin del otro lado de la moneda está
rusia y en el consejo de seguridad de
las naciones unidas hoy el representante
de rusia ante la onu basili neves jan
también habló sobre este tema escuchemos
nos guiamos ante todo porque lo más
importante es la preservación de la vida
de las personas al criticarnos por esta
decisión ustedes demuestran la completa
indiferencia frente al destino de los
habitantes de tony así lugares como lo
han hecho kiev y sus aliados
occidentales estos 8 años por eso nos
llamó hoy a concentrar sus esfuerzos en
calmar a kiev y convencerlos de no
emprender nuevas aventuras armadas que
le pueden salir muy caras a los actuales
dirigentes ucranianos es
un
tema de coyuntura internacional lo vamos
a analizar aquí en el debate de france
24 para ello hemos invitado a manuel
superville él es coronel retirado del
ejército de eeuu experto en seguridad
internacional está en la ciudad de miami
en el sur del estado de la florida
también es consultor y también se une a
esta conversación desde la ciudad de
buenos aires en argentina ignacio útil
él es analista de política internacional
columnista también es colaborador de
varios medios internacionales es autor
de algunos libros sólo por mencionar
algunos el libro ucrania donbass una
renovada guerra fría
crónica desde el frente a ambos les
agradezco por estar acompañándonos hoy
en el debate de france 24 les recuerdo
que ustedes los televidentes también
pueden participar en el programa con
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas lo
pueden hacer a través de las redes
sociales les recuerdo estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24 guión bajo es sant
y luego que es mi cuenta personal les
recuerdo la etiqueta numeral el debate
efe 24 pues tenemos el contexto esto
está cambiando minuto a minuto todo lo
que está sucediendo allí en ucrania pero
vamos a analizar por lo menos los
últimos hechos representativos de las
últimas horas y comienzos entonces con
manuel en preguntándole por estas
sanciones que llegan desde washington y
desde los 27 países de la unión europea
a rusia
servirán estas sanciones de qué sirven
las sanciones contra un país como rusia
que ha demostrado poder combatirlas y
poder hacerle frente a lo que le impone
occidente en términos económicos
bueno este gracias por la invitación
estar aquí con ustedes
yo diría que todavía si van a funcionar
llegar a los objetivos que requiere que
apuntan no sabemos si no vamos a saber
por un tiempo pero típicamente un estado
soberano
toma diferentes medidas incrementar
nuestras palabras empiezan con la parte
diplomática
la parte de información
vamos a la guerra o acciones
cibernéticas y después ya llegas a la
parte
económica y lo final sería la parte
militar así que en este caso ya esto es
la unión europea de eeuu canadá y gran
bretaña ya han llegado a ese cuarto
punto no la parte de economía ya todo lo
demás su diplomática la parte
diplomática la parte informática
y ahora estamos en las en la fase
económica lo que queda sería la militar
la cual todo el mundo quiere evitar si
es posible que es el escenario que el
mundo entero espera que no
comienza a ignacio en la ciudad de
buenos aires- su opinión sobre estas
sanciones es el proceso indicado para
evitar precisamente ese escenario final
de llegar a un conflicto a una incursión
militar de rusia a gran escala en
territorio ucraniano
creo que por ahora es la única
alternativa
occidente no tiene otra alternativa que
no sean las sanciones porque si las
funciones no funcionan lo único que
queda es la vía militar y yo aún creo
aún con esta escalada de tensión tan
importante aún creo que la otan quiere
evitar una guerra abierta con rusia a
toda costa el problema es que ya ya se
impusieron sanciones sobre rusia hace
ocho años que rusia tiene sanciones
comerciales muy importantes y eso no ha
significado un cambio de rumbo para el
kremlin de ninguna forma entonces creo
que si bien las sanciones son a esta
altura la única alternativa no me parece
que puedan llegar a funcionar porque
además como si fuera poco
distintas empresas grandes empresas
occidentales tienen inversiones muy
importantes en rusia empezando por las
empresas ligadas a la energía a los
hidrocarburos con lo cual las sanciones
comerciales que se apliquen sobre a
rusia también van a repercutir va a
haber una suerte de efecto rebote y van
a afectar al propio occidente entonces
no me parece que esto pueda funcionar
quiero creer que sí porque la única
alternativa en la vía bélica si me
parece que nadie quiere una guerra hago
la ronda a la inversa sigo con ignacio
en la ciudad de buenos aires ya le doy
la palabra a manuel y le pregunto por
las sanciones que impuso estados unidos-
dos bancos en particular un barco un
banco que a los ojos de occidente es un
fondo de inversión del kremlin que sirve
supuestamente para pagar sobornos eso lo
que han dicho algunas investigaciones en
occidente pero no hay prueba de ello y
un banco que está enfocado netamente en
la industria militar rusa pero hablando
del sistema financiero muchos esperaban
que en washington y pusiera entonces
controles al sistema internacional swift
que es un sistema que facilita las
transacciones internacionales y esto no
es lo que ha anunciado washington
prácticamente deja al sberbank y haya
otros bancos rusos con total libertad
para seguir teniendo transacciones
internacionales esto sí afecta a estos
dos bancos estatales si los afectan
estas sanciones como lo vio usted
sí absolutamente pero a mí me interesa
mucho más las sanciones
individuales las sanciones que se
aplican sobre individuos creo que ello
es mucho más importante que las
sanciones sobre un banco que porque en
general estas sanciones que se aplicaron
sobre individuos son a individuos
particularmente importantes a individuos
particularmente ricos oligarcas los
famosos oligarcas rusos
y esos estos hombres estos individuos
son los que tienen el poder están muy
cerca del kremlin muy cerca del útil y
tienen mucho dinero tienen inversiones
en europa tienen inmuebles en europa
especialmente en francia y en inglaterra
y tienen mucho acceso al crimen tienen
mucho acceso al poder preciso entonces
me parece mucho más interesante estas
sanciones sobre individuos que las
sanciones sobre el sistema financiero
ruso sólo por mencionar algunos de estos
integrantes de la élite e ignacio
mencionó está el jefe de espionaje ruso
alexandr bórtnikov su hijo denis el sub
jefe de gabinete presidencial sérguei
kirienko y su hijo vladimir también está
el director ejecutivo del psv que es
este banco militar del que estábamos
hablando él se llama pieter franco y son
algunos de los integrantes de esta lista
que afecta a la llamada élite cercana al
kremlin allí en rusia manuel en la
ciudad de miami que busca eeuu con esta
forma de presión de sanciones espera que
rusia
regrese su determinación de ver ha
conocido a estas dos repúblicas
separatistas o espera que simplemente
putin se siente a dialogar con
washington y con bruselas que es lo que
está buscando washington que sea el paso
inmediato por parte de rusia
bueno antes antes de contestar eso si me
permite
contribuir a la pregunta ante algo hacia
adelante de acuerdo si estoy de acuerdo
que esto de sancionar a personas muy
importantes que están muy cerca al señor
putin es estoy totalmente acuerdo es muy
importante porque hay que tener en
cuenta que el gobierno de rusia es
actualmente una oligarca donde hay un
grupo pequeño de personas que son súper
súper ricos con billonarios y
afectarlos a ellos no es como si
estuviéramos afectando a una empresa de
un país por ejemplo yo no maurer de eeuu
o algo por el estilo así que eso sí yo
creo que es algo que hay que tener en
cuenta y también que en esta fase de lo
que ha hecho hasta ahora
rusia no es no es el final en otras
palabras que hay que tener unas medidas
y estas sanciones tienen que estar
preparadas e implementadas de una forma
en fases incrementando porque si se
fuera a jugar todo de una vez al
principio entonces no quedan otras
medidas para el futuro depende de qué es
lo que haga rusia porque hasta ahora lo
que ha hecho rusia puede ser que sea muy
pequeño en comparación a lo que pueda
hacer en un futuro así que esos puntos
en referencia a las acciones que lo que
vino ahora como dijo el presidente paren
y la unión europea esta es la primera
fase de sanciones que son por encima de
lo que había antes cuando primero
empezaron a apoyar indirectamente a las
áreas de separación
y lo que le preguntaba que buscar
entonces este primer tramo que usted nos
ha explicado ese es un primer paso que
da a washington que paso es el que
buscan del otro lado de moscú que moscú
entonces reverse es su idea de reconocer
la independencia de donges y lugansk o
que
abra la puerta para una mesa de diálogo
con washington y bruselas y con kiev
cual quiere usted que puede hacer el
paso que está buscando washington bueno
yo me imagino que obvio lo lo que buscan
lo que desean lo que desean sería que
rusia que putin se fuera a retroceder de
lo que ha hecho hasta ahora pero eso yo
creo que nadie en realidad cree que eso
va a ocurrir así que entonces más que
nada vamos a ir del punto de vista
realista es que esto vaya a empezar a
ponerle los frenos
al autor de pulp en que está manejando
con todos estos otros oligarcas y que
empiecen a frenar la velocidad en cual
van y entonces ahí crear situaciones en
que mientras que van avanzando los
costos
la fórmula de álgebra no del
costo-beneficio
empieza a cambiar para que le llegue de
ser más costo que lo que si fueran a
seguir y en esto quiero comentar que que
ahí no hay unanimidad dentro de rusia
para estas acciones y especialmente
dentro de las fuerzas armadas en los
retirados generales ha habido bastante
este pensamiento en contra de lo que
está haciendo porque ellos saben que si
se fueran a meter de una forma total en
la ucrania ahí se va a formar una cosa
una situación muy muy difícil para rusia
claro será muy difícil para rusia para
ucrania por supuesto para el resto de
europa es el escenario que están
tratando de evitar por lo menos con
todos los canales diplomáticos abiertos
desde hace varias semanas esto es como
una especie de partido donde la pelota
va y viene de un lado a otro ignacio en
manuel y quiero que veamos la
perspectiva de rusia porque en este
momento el balón ha caído ya en moscú
después de esta respuesta que ha dado la
unión europea y eeuu con las sanciones
como puede reaccionar rusia ante esto ya
han sido claros desde el kremlin a
través de los representantes en
diferentes organismos internacionales la
respuesta rusa va a ser contundente a
estas sanciones comienzo con ignacio
nación de buenos aires ahora vemos este
rompecabezas que puede hacer rusia ahora
es una muy buena pregunta que pueda
hacer rusia porque yo creo que
económicamente en términos financieros
en términos económicos en términos de
comercio no puedo hacer mucho
yo creo que rusia sabía esperaba estas
sanciones que fueron muy anunciadas y
probablemente espera la segunda etapa de
las sanciones que como decía manuel será
mucho más dura
creo que putin no habría tomado nunca la
decisión que tomó el avanzar hacia hacia
territorio ucraniano el reconocer a la
república popular de daniel y a la
república popular de lugansk nunca lo
hubiera hecho si no supiera si no
tuviera la certeza de que cuenta con una
red de seguridad y esa red de seguridad
creo yo se llama china si si rusia no
puede comerciar más con el occidente si
las sanciones son muy duras si si lo
quitan de todos los sistemas financieros
que lo conecten con occidente rusia
simplemente se da vuelta y empieza a
comerciar más que nunca con china y eso
me parece un dato fundamental no me
parece que rusia se pueda dar una
respuesta a estas sanciones creo que no
tiene una capacidad económica como para
hacerlo ignacio y que tan dispuesta está
china a quedar involucrada en este
conflicto en esta crisis internacional
al permitirle a rusia a no sé acceder a
su sistema financiero hacia
transacciones a través de bancos chinos
o acceder a préstamos entre beijing y
moscú esta china dispuesta a meterse ahí
y a recibir esa presión internacional
que le puede llegar también por parte de
eeuu con quien ya tiene una relación
bastante tensa
es cierto china tiene una relación
bastante tensa con eeuu y también tiene
una relación bastante tensa con
distintos gobiernos del occidente
europeo pero aún así comercia aún así es
el principal socio comercial de ucrania
por ejemplo y es uno de los principales
socios comerciales del mismo eeuu con lo
cual no me parece me parece que son dos
caminos que van en paralelo por un lado
las relaciones políticas y por el otro
las relaciones comerciales y los
distintos estados nos han demostrado en
estos últimos años que con china se
privilegia las relaciones comerciales
porque los productos chinos son muy
baratos son muy accesibles y es muy
difícil competir con eso manuel y para
complementar este rompecabezas y cerrar
esta esta ronda le repito la pregunta
entonces
que puede entonces hacia rusia si china
le podrá dar una mano o algún otro
aliado a nivel internacional digamos
venezuela nicaragua aquí en américa
latina y otros cuantos países que tiene
aliados en los diferentes continentes
como lo ve usted
bueno mire
al fin del día cuando uno habla de
comercio ahí tiene que haber algún tipo
de servicio o producto que se vende
porque ese es el comercio no es no es
simplemente vamos a ir las sanciones en
la parte del fluido de los dólares o los
rumbos russo eso es importante porque
eso no puede frenar hasta cierto punto
pero al fin del día
russia ganas la mayoría de su ingreso es
por la venta del petróleo y del gas
natural y eso la mayoría se lo vende a
europa y entonces estoy de acuerdo que
esto va a haber costos
estas sanciones van a haber costos
especialmente para alemania y para otras
partes de europa en el sentido de que se
va a disminuir se puede disminuir este
aceptar y recibir el gas natural de
rusia como usted bien digo al inicio por
el momento se ha cerrado el tema de nord
stream 2 que eso le va a costar a
alemania y no solamente alemán ya otros
países de la marca y otros pero al fin
del día están aceptando que esto es algo
que les va a venir a un costo así que
para ellos también están haciendo ese
cálculo que vale la pena y lo que quiero
decir con eso entonces
totten se va a quedar corto en términos
de ganancias de recursos económicos
simplemente porque no está vendiendo lo
mismo y yo no creo que china y la manera
de cómo llegar vamos a decir hasta ahora
al momento tienen planes pero al momento
no hay ninguna manera fácil de cómo
transferir el gas natural ni el petróleo
desde rusia a china aunque tengan su
frontera común porque es son unas
distancias enorme obvio claro así que
eso eso yo creo que es el problema para
obtener que no es la parte de las
sanciones en en los instrumentos del
comercio si es más en la fundación de la
falta del comercio porque ya no tienen
los bienes para vender claro manuel yo
tenía el tema de alemania y del
gasoducto del norte string para tratar
lo más adelante pero ya que usted lo
menciona me parece pertinente continuar
con eso antes de hablar de la
perspectiva ucraniana de todas estas
sanciones y aquí el mayor beneficiado de
toda esta jugada es eeuu que será
entonces aquí en euro tendrá que
comprarle que era lo que washington
estaba buscando desde hace muchos meses
al impedirle a europa y alemania
específicamente poder activar el norte
stream para abastecerse de gas y las
discrepancias comenzaron incluso antes
del invierno que ya está por terminar y
washington tal parece que entonces como
dicen le sonó la flauta
bueno este sí primero que nada en
términos de la presión pública porque en
contrario a la rusia los los estados de
europa el
alemania francia dinamarca etcétera si
tienen que responder los los que
gobiernan tienen que responder a su
pueblo entonces imagínense cierto bien
si esto estuviera pasando vamos a decir
en noviembre cuando comienza el invierno
y hay la perspectiva de que este
invierno encima del cover y todo lo
demás también tienen que quedarse cortos
de calefacción por medio del gas natural
hubiera sido un problema mucho
políticamente domésticamente
políticamente mucho más difícil para los
países de europa claridad como usted
dice ya estamos casi aquí en marzo y en
eso fue un fallo yo no diría que es un
juego de tenis albert o más como un
juego de ajedrez de cuatro dimensiones
lo que se está jugando
y entonces lo
el parte de north stream quien se abroga
pasar pero también usted tienes razón y
la cosa es que los eeuu si tiene la
capacidad como usted sabe que en los
últimos años ha sido un país que exporta
más
energía claro el petróleo y el gas que
que lo que importa si tiene la capacidad
del fracking que se hace en varios
estados sin manuel para reemplazar para
tuesta mente exactamente para allá va mi
pregunta le pido que sea muy muy
concreto justamente eso era lo que
quería eeuu llegará al mercado europeo
necesitaba que europa le comprara ese
superávit de producción que tiene ahora
no no creo que sea tan fácil mire porque
aquí también hay la política doméstica
en contra de más
ranking de estas cosas es un balance así
que yo creo que es más la parte
estratégica de decirle a los alemanes y
los europeos si llega a esta crisis
claro y rusia corta entonces aquí
estamos para reemplazar pero no es que
eeuu lo estaba buscando como una manera
geopolítica para vender más al contrario
están tratando de recortar manuel e
ignacio ya me quedan pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa su opinión sobre
este tema de el cierre la suspensión de
la puesta en marcha del norte string
cómo afecta esto a europa que tampoco
tiene el poderío militar que puede tener
eeuu en caso de una incursión de rusia
en el este del continente a muy cerca de
las fronteras con la unión europea y
ahora pues tampoco va a tener ese
abastecimiento extra de gas que llegaba
desde rusia su opinión
sí yo creo que alemania va a ser muy
duramente afectado por esto en principio
porque es el principal consumidor de la
unión europea de gas ruso de hecho la ex
canciller angela merkel había apoyado
muy fuertemente la construcción del
norte twin2 porque bueno le representa
mayor cantidad de gas a un precio mucho
menor pero pero ahora con esta función
con con el cierre del gasoducto con la
no certificación mejor dicho del
gasoducto de la mano de olaf scholz creo
que esto va a afectar económicamente a
alemania y si bien puede buscar alguna
alternativa puede buscar algún otro país
para suplir la falta de gas desde rusia
pasar más caro va a ser mucho más caro
al menos el 50 por ciento y hay que ver
qué opinan los alemanes de este aumento
de precio para el cierre para este
último bloque quiero hablar de la
perspectiva ucraniana veíamos las
declaraciones del presidente volodymyr
selenski agradeciendo a la comunidad
internacional ya sus aliados de
occidente por imponer estas sanciones
también ucrania que más cartas tiene
para jugar
ignacio allí en la ciudad de buenos
aires- que más puede jugar en todo este
escenario porque vemos que es mucho
rifirrafe entre bruselas con menos menos
tensión que con washington y moscú y
kiev está en la mitad pero que más allá
de la diplomacia puede jugar ucrania y
agradecer a sus aliados internacionales
para evitar una posible invasión evitar
más tensión con moscú
ucrania no puede hacer mucho el ejército
ucraniano no es muy fuerte de hecho al
inicio de la guerra hace casi 8 años los
que llevaron adelante los principales
avances del estado ucraniano fueron
organizaciones paramilitares porque el
estado ucraniano no podía sostener al
ejército no estaba preparado no tenía
financiación no tenía armamento
suficiente no me parece que ucrania
puede hacer mucho más que diplomacia sin
los aportes de la otan aportes
financieros aportes de armas aportes de
quizás de soldados quién sabe ucraniano
puede hacerles frente al ejército ruso
de ninguna forma creo que la única
opción que tiene es la vía diplomática y
esperar que los distintos países
europeos o miembros de la otan le
aporten tanto dinero como armamento
manuel su opinión en la ciudad de miami
la perspectiva ucraniana que más pueden
hacer desde kiev para bajar un poco la
atención y evitar un conflicto
bueno yo estoy de acuerdo que las
fuerzas armadas pero 6 de ucrania
están muy débil y no van a poder hacer
mucho en contra de las fuerzas armadas
rusas y de belarús también pero
acuérdense que el asalto tomar posesión
inicialmente es mucho más fácil que
mantener control y posesión y acuérdense
de eeuu en vietnam acuérdense en rusia
en afganistán y muchas otras historias
de diferentes imperios que quedan
aprendido esta lección es lo que quiero
decir es que toman a ucrania vamos a ir
si fueran a tomar ucrania totalmente los
rusos hoy en día las fuerzas armadas no
van a poder defender mucho pero el
pueblo ucranio que se siente muy
patriota muy nacionalista no se va a
quedar callado y hoy en día con todo el
mundo con un teléfono celular que pueden
mostrar cualquier tipo de abuso de
derechos humanos o de abusos de la ley
es la ley de guerra de los convenios de
ginebra etcétera les van a causar un
daño de imagen público que no solamente
internacionalmente sino también dentro
del pueblo ruso que se sienten muy cerca
al pueblo ucranio
eso apunten les va a ser muy peligroso
manuel rápidamente para el cierre
ignacio también entra la otan en un
conflicto armado allí en el este de
ucrania
manuel yo digo que no que eso
no es algo que lo que lo que acabo de
mencionar que hay maneras ya después de
que de apoyar a una resistencia así que
una conflicto de ard de soldados
americanos no lo dudo
e ignacio
concuerdo completamente creo que nadie
ni en moscú ni en washington ni en
ningún lado quiere una guerra abierta
entre la otan y moscú eso sería
catastrófico para la seguridad no sólo
de europa sino de todo el planeta me
parece que la otan va a evitar esa
posibilidad a toda costa me queda un
minuto para cerrar el programa quiero
hacer las conclusiones ignacio que va a
suceder esto cambia minuto a minuto cada
momento hay una declaración distinta de
alguna de las partes implicadas en toda
esta crisis que puede suceder en las
próximas horas en esta escalada de
tensión allí en el este de ucrania
comienzo con ignacio en buenos aires
yo creo que un factor fundamental es el
reconocimiento ruso a las repúblicas
populares de daniels y de lugansk en
todo el territorio de la provincia no
solo en las regiones controladas por las
autoridades separatistas porque el
reconocer a todo el territorio como
parte de estas repúblicas implica avalar
una avanzada para reconquistar o re
controlar estos territorios entonces
creo que eso puede pasar en las próximas
horas una avanzada militar al menos para
controlar la totalidad de las regiones
de danielle y de lugansk que tenemos
visto movimientos de tanques desde el
lado ruso hacia la frontera con ucrania
y también varios tanques rusos que ya
estaban dentro del territorio
separatista moviéndose un poco más hacia
el sur hacia el puerto de mariupol allí
en el mar de azov que también es un
punto estratégico a nivel militar para
una posible incursión a gran escala que
puede ser un escenario en los próximos
días o en las próximas horas para el
cierre manuel su conclusión sobre este
tema que puede suceder
yo estoy de acuerdo creo que eso sería
como próximo movimiento en esa tabla de
ajedrez en cuatro dimensiones
porque esa es la acción de tomar el
resto de las dos provincias
tendría un costo un coste o vamos a ir
por encima de lo que ya han hecho hasta
ahora pero no tanto más pero si les trae
dos tercios más de lo que el momento
tiene control de putter así que el costo
adicional es pequeño
y el territorio que para él es
importantísimo tener esa zona de defensa
en contra de otan
le conviene mucho y eso es un beneficio
alto a un costo menor ahora ya cuando
pasan de esa esa frontera la vivan al
resto del ucrania entonces ahí al post o
se va a aumentar muchísimo a largo plazo
pues a manuel y a ignacio a nuestros
invitados del programa de hoy les
agradezco por haber hecho este análisis
y haber explicado para la audiencia de
france 24 sus puntos y sus perspectivas
en torno a esta escalada de tensión allí
en el este de ucrania en el este de
europa les agradezco mucho por haber
estado con nosotros en el programa de
ustedes muchas gracias por la sintonía
les recuerdo pueden seguir dejando todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales del canal los
invito a seguir en sintonía de france24
sigan con nosotros
[Música]